よろしくお願いします
また この阿羅漢になった方々の心の状況ってどういうものかということを説明している章ですね
今日は三九九で アッコーサンワデダンダンチェアドゥントーヨーティティンカティ・カンティバランバラーニカンタメハンルーミブラフマナン
アッコーサンワデダンダンチェアドゥントーヨーティティンカティ・カンティバランバラーニカンタメハンルーミブラフマナン
アッコーサン いわゆる侮辱することですね
すごく叱ること ワデダンダンというのは
暴力されることですね
拷問とかね そういうものはワデバン
ワデっていうのはすごく体にいろんな痛みつけること
バンダンっていうのはいろんな縛っておくとかね
そういうこと アッコーサン
まあもうかなりきつい言葉でまあ侮辱される
それからワデバンダン
暴力振るわれる そういうものをアドゥント
全く心に嫌な気持ちがなくて
怒りがなくて ティティッカティ
忍耐する 次に アドゥントっていうのは心には怒りがないということで
いわゆるまあ嫌な気持ちはしません
たとえいくら侮辱されても
まあ全然心で何も思わないと
それワデっていうのは
いろんなものを拷問されたり
いじめられたりしても
全然何も気にしません
バンダンというのは自由を奪うことですね
いわゆる縛っておいたり
なんとかすることですね
そんなことをしたっても全然気にしないと
というのはアドゥント
心に嫌な気持ちなくティティッカティ
忍耐する 次の言葉は カンティバランバラーニカンと
で その人のバラーニカン
もう大変な軍隊は持っています
どういう軍隊かと カンティバラン
忍耐という強力な軍隊を持っているんだから
まああまり気にしない
で カンティバラン カンティもやっぱり忍耐という意味なんですね
まあティティッカティっていう言葉は
この嫌なことを やっぱりそれも忍耐でね
まあ我慢するということではないんですけど
まあ忍耐する そこでこの聖者が
このいろんなひどいことを落ち着いて
何のことなく忍耐して
それをそのまま受け取って
何のことなく流すという
そのこと自体が自分のすごい強力な力にしているんですよ
だからそれこそ仏教のものすごい違うところで
怒りに怒り 敵に敵ということはもう一片かけらもない
だから仏教を力としているのは忍耐
怒らないことなんですね
心を平安に持つこと たとえどんな状況の中にいても
だから世界の生き方とはものすごい正反対です
正反対といっても これが正しい生き方で
誰もやってみないだけのことです
忍耐ある人はどこに立っても必ず何の問題もなく
もう大変ないい結果になります
このあるバラモン人の奥さんがね
名前はダナンジャエ ダナンジャエニ
で このアッコスワラドージャってのは有名な人なんですけど
彼女の奥さんがなんか密かに仏教徒なんですね
で バラモンはバラモンですからね
自分も宗教家だからそれで
で あの彼女は本当に三宝に帰依して
まあ預流果に悟っていて
だから変わらない確信を持ってるんですね
まあとにかくこのバラモン教の習慣っていうのは
いつでも何か呪文唱えてるわとかね
もうオームオームとかオームシャーンティとか
もうなんとか まあ現代ヒンドゥー教だったらね
何でしたっけ ランでしたっけね
え？ オーム・ナマ・シヴァヤ
それはある特別な宗派ですけどね
だいたい一般的なヒンドゥー教はヘー・ランかオー・ランかどちらんですよ
ヘー・ランですね で 普通の公のヒンドゥー教はヘー・ラン
ヘー・ランと言ってるんですね
オーム・ナマ・シヴァヤっていうのは
ある特別な宗派の言葉
一般的にはあまり使わない
まあとにかく何か口に
口にすす 何て言いますかね
口ずさむ  うん 口ずさんでいるんですよ
で  それはね まあどこでも人間がやってることで
まあチベット仏教の人たちもオーム・パニ・パドメ・ホームというものをずっとまあ口ずさんでるし
まあ我々テーラワーダ仏教の場合はね
まあ「行きとし来るものが
聖裸であり申すように」ということをいつでも口ずさんでるし
うーん まあ普通の信者さんはまあ口ずさんでる
まあいつでもまあサッベー・サッター・バング・サクカッターっていう偈ですね
それぞれまあナモー・タッダ・プッタ・シーラね
いろいろあります で まあキリスト教の人たちもそういうものあるしね
まあそういうことだから
彼女はいつでもまあ ナモー・タッサー・バゴ・トー・ワラー・トー・サンマー・サンブッダって
まあブッダに あの 礼拝をする文章を
まあいつでも口でも言ってるんですね
だからなんか呪文唱えてるような感じで言ってるでしょうね
おそらく 長い呪文やらね
ヴェーダ聖典でも長い文章もいろいろありますよ
ヨーティーマー・タモソーマー・ヨーティーラジェとかね
で 今はもうほとんど忘れちゃったんだけど
いろいろありますよ  えーと
だいたいヴェーダ聖典は一番最初の偈をよく覚えていることなんですね
みんな あれはサーヴィトゥリーという
あれはサン ブッダの三偈と同じ節で作ってるんです
うん だから三偈もその真似で成り立ったんではないかという意見もあります
まあどうせヴェーダ時期が古いんですからね
まあとにかく彼女はいつでも
まあ何があろうとも咳が出ようが
くしゃみが出ようが すぐそれ言っちゃいますね
ナモ・タッサ・バガタ・ワラ・ハト
まあそれだけのことやと思いますけどね
それである日 この彼の旦那がね
まあブラマン教だから
まあ自分の宗教のいろいろしきたりいっぱいありまして
ある日自分の宗教の行事ですね
まあブラマンたちたくさん自分の家に呼んで接待しているんですね
それで彼女は一生懸命忙しくていろいろ世話している時でも
なんか足をこけて倒れこけちゃったんです
そこで何のことなく もう声を出して
もうこの経文章を言ったんですね
ナモ・タッサ・バガタ・ワラ・ハト・サンマ・サンブダ
だからそれでバラモンたちはものすごいもう機嫌が悪くなったんですね
なんで私たちの前にこのハゲの沙門のムンダカス・サマナス・ワンナン・バーサティ
だからお釈迦様が邪教で
もう全くもう不可触民足と一緒やっていう風に
このバラモンたちたちがもうもうすごくそう思っているんですね
それもほとんど陰で公ではできなかったことで
結局公では何の立場も力もなかったんです
法でいえばね だから一般もう陰ではよく言っていたんですね
特に気に入らなかったのは
この頭剃っていることなんですね
それはブラマン人はしません
すごいそれに反対 で それの言うがてこの王様なんかは
こうやって人を非国民にする場合はね
非国民とする場合は この頭は全部剃らしちゃうんですね
剃らして この灰を塗って
もう人間ではないと この国民でもないと追い出すんです
その場合は殺すことはしません
で いわゆる人間失格にするんですね
その時やっていることも頭を剃るです
剃って灰を頭に全部塗って追い出すんです
このシヴァ信仰でそれをやっているんです
ヒンドゥー教のシヴァ信仰の宗派が頭を剃って灰を塗るということをしています
で でもブラフマンブラマン教というか
ヒンドゥー教はもともとはもう髪の毛剃るということ自体が大変な良くない恥だと
で いわゆる階級宗教だからね
このカースト制度 自分の社会的な立場
どれぐらい金持ってるかとかね
どれぐらいかっこいいか
美しいか そういうことでもう基準決めちゃ決めていたんです
だからお釈迦様の時代のブラマン人っていうのは
そんなにもう今流行ってるヒンドゥー教みたいな
そんなことはなかったんですけどね
で 特に家柄がよく  7代目まであること
それからものすごいこの美しい体で生まれること
だから人相やらね 全部完璧に揃って立派な家で生まれる
まあ一応ブラマン人が見てもまあほとんどないんですけどね
体の体格なんかいい人っていうのは
シャトリヤ系の人々はものすごいすごい体格があるんですよ
もし見ることでき ないね
今のではなくて このインドの前のネール首相とかね
見ただけでびっくりするんですよ
私はネールさんの娘さんがね
見て本当に驚いちゃったんだから
この人で何者かと すっごい圧倒されるんですよ
別に若い若い女の子っていうことでもないんだから
若だからね そんなところじゃないんです
ものすごいんですね あの体
ものすごい このいろんなこの文献では教えている
この花の葉っぱの色 花の花びらの色と言った方がよろしいんですよ
なんかすごいピンク色ですごくものすごい皮膚の色っていうのはすごいんです
だからそういうこのシャトリヤ族の人々は結構まあ体格というかね
すごい男も女もすごい綺麗でしたけどね
バラモン人も結構見たことがあるんだけど
中が出てきてないし まあぐちゃぐちゃですよ
あれで髪のあれかと聞きたいところなんですけどね
だから結局バラモン人はシャトリヤ族のお世話係ばっかりやっていたんですね
自分たちの中でも綺麗な人が
子供が男が生まれたらもうかなり売れちゃいますね
それで だからそういうものなんですね
財産があることとかね
褒めてあって それからすごい学者であることとかね
それからヴェーダ聖典はきちんと丸暗記して
注釈書までね 全部丸暗記しているかないかとか
まあそれぐらいのことで
お釈迦様そんなものは全部片っ端からまあ捨てちゃいますね
あるバラモンが五つ言ったんですよ
この家柄の美しいこと
それからこの経典 聖典とかなどなど勉強していることとか
それ言って それからこの道徳的な人間であることと
智慧であるかって それはとですね
ですから それあれば完璧なバラモン人で
聖者で褒めるべきですよとお釈迦様に言うんです
五つそれっていうのは
お釈迦様 ああそうですか
で あなたに聞くんだけど
もしその五つで一つ消すんだったらね
あなたどちら消す消すんでしょうかと言ったら
彼が彼の知識人だから
それだったらこの体格を美しくて
そんなものはどうでもいいでしょうに
どうせ年取ったらね まあ醜くなっちゃうし
だからあれはあまり意味がないんだよって
一応消しちゃったんですね
四つさえそれであと四つそれればいいって
そうですね で また聞きますけど
この四つの中で一つ消せないんでしょうかねと
だからこの何て言いますかね
この家柄とかね なんとかそれ一つ消しちゃったんですね
それなくたってもいいんじゃないかと
母親で 家はまあちょっと何かあったって別にそれはもうただの家柄ではなくて
この家の代々 そのそんなことはあんまり人間としてはなくてもいいやと消すんですね
もう一つ消せないかと
また聞いたら 次も消しちゃいますね
ヴェーダ聖典云々など
それで二つ残っちゃったんです
そこでバラモン人に だから立派なバラモン人で聖者になるためには
まあ条件二つしか残ってないんです
結局自分の宗教はもうとっくに捨てられてるんです
知らないうちに お釈迦様が次にこの二つで一つまた消せないんでしょうかと
言っちゃうと  四番目は道徳的な人間であること
五番目は智慧のあること
これはこのバラモン人
なかなか消せないんですよ
道徳ないってのは非道徳的な
ものすごい悪い生活をしてもいいわけにはいきませんしね
頭が全く悪くて智慧ひとかけらもないというわけにも
お釈迦様 これがちょっと無理ですよと
消せないんだと でお釈迦様
その通りですよ 人間には道徳と智慧があればよろしいですよ
それで完璧だと という
まあお釈迦様のこの対話っていうのは
本当にもうすごいんですよ
だから何の事なく あのバラモン人も知らないうちに自分でもう捨ててるんで
自分の宗教は でお互いに賛成するんです
その通りですと 私もいくら考えたって
もうこのシーラとパンニャーは全くももうお互いにあってかみ合って捨てられませんと
一つはシーラがあればパンニャー完成するんだと
パンニャーがあればシーラも完成するんだと
だから私の意見もそういう意見だよと言って
彼にそう言って 彼にシーラとパンニャーの世界を教えちゃったんです
あれもすごい 満足して帰るんですよ
だからもうそういう風な
ものすごい平和的で智慧でお釈迦様はね
人々に真理の道を教えるんですね
ですから それはそれで
この頭を剃る いわゆる剃るっていうことはね
当時のバラモン人たちが色欲
色的な次元で見ていたんだから
あまり嫌がっていたんですね
それでこのバラモンのヒンドゥー
大本のバラモン教に反対して
反対派がたくさん出たんですよ
過激派みたいな その反対派まとめてで
今みんなヒンドゥー教やとかいろんなことを言ってますと
特に外国で知ってるのは反対派なんですよ
メインストリームの主流のインドのヒンドゥー教はほとんど外国で知ってないんです
だから反対派だから どうせインドで少数派だから
その人々も結局金目当てで生活しているし
いろんな外国なんかに行って自分で何か教えちゃうんですね
これがヨーガやこれは何とかやとか
何とかと言って教えちゃいますけど
インドに行ってみれば
それはどこにも見つからないんですよ
だからアメリカやらイギリスやらいろんなところでヒンドゥー教はかなり人気ありますね
そこで何か習って じゃあ本場インドに行ってみようかなと言ったら全く違います
見つからない そういう先生知ってますか？と
誰も知りません すごい先生
あ そう それで終わっちゃうんです
別にもう もうすごい先生っていうこと
インド人にとってはもう別にないんだからね
まあそれはまあ当たり前やって言われる通り言われるんだけどね
インドってのはそんなもんやと
いっぱいいるんだと そこら辺にいくらでもという感じでね
でもすごい人っていうのは稀ですけどね
知識はありますけどね
まあそういうことだから
お釈迦様にも陰で隠れてね
ハゲということも言っていましたしね
今この聖なる灰とかなんとか言って塗ってますけどね
昔は聖なる灰じゃなくて
あれはこの 何て言いますか
人間でないという風にも
人間を追い出す時の使ったものなんです
ハゲ塗ったらもう家も消されるんですよ
名前も使ってはいけません
例えばバラモン人の家であろうとも
シャトゥリヤ族の家であろうとも
それからは両親の名前を使ってはいけません
もうカーストまで消しちゃいます
だからインド社会では人間扱いされません
もう社会に入れません
どんな枠に入れるかという
それでこの不可触民族というか
この社会から追い出されたグループに入らなくちゃいけないんですね
それが一番首にするよりは
殺すよりは一番きつい罰なんです
普通 泥棒したり 何とかしたらすぐ首を飛ばしちゃいますね
まあそれビシッと死ぬだけですけどね
それよりものすごい激しくきつい罰を与えたければ
そういうふうにしちゃうんです
だからそれがこの行者たちなんかはね
わざとその儀式を自分で受けて家を出ましたと
ということをする 自分でそういう儀式をして社会を出るんだから
だから当時の法律によって捕まえないんです
もう人間ではないんだから
だから動物が人を襲っても動物に裁判にかけませんでしょ
どうにもどうにもできませんね
ですからもう動物は誰かの家に入って
何か盗んで食べちゃっても
出ていけと追い出すだけで
それで終わり 人が人の家に入っちゃって
何か取って行ったらまた大変
泥棒扱いされて法律で裁くんですね
だから法律適用するのは
この法律というか この何法律ですか
この罰を決めるこの刑法ですね
刑法適用するのは人間なんです
そこで自分でああいう儀式
王様がしてでも 自分で勝手にしてでも
社会から出たらもう刑法は適用しません
それで当時インドではやっぱりそういうわけで
大体宗教家は自由にしているんです
していたんです だから国から国へも行けるし
何も聞きません 最近までインドでも電車に乗っても電車でも汽車ですけどね
乗っても誰も気にしない
チケットどうしますかとかね
聞かない そのままいて
どこかに座り込んじゃって
いるんです だからインド横断しちゃっても
結構お金かかりますけどね
そこでチケットチェックするわ
いろいろするわ いろいろありますよ
見て もう全然なかったことにしてやっちゃうんです
行者の場合は だから  そういう習慣なんですね
今は別にあれはもう もう人間じゃないサービスっていうことではなくても
まあ今は行者っていうことでやっていることで
別に尊敬とくことでもないんだけど
放っておくんですね どうせ何も持ってないってことは知ってるし
チケットどうですか？って言ったって持ってないし
お金払えって言ったって別に持ってるわけじゃないし
だけどどうすることもできない
それで捕まって 何かにどこかに入れていたっても
その人にとってはどうったことはない
どこにいたっても同じことだから
だからもうどうにもならん
例えば警察にも預ける
そうするとそこで入れるでしょ
檻に 俺にとって別にそこで座り込んでるんだから
[笑い]だからもうなかったことに
いなかったことにするしか方法はないんです
それでこの悪い罪を犯した人々も
バレる前にすぐそういうことをする場合もあります
捕まったら首をとびますから
先に自分でそうやって家を出ちゃう
出ちゃうと もう名前も何も使う必要はないし
好き勝手な何か名前を使えばよろしいし
家は誰々やって関係なくなっちゃうし
で わからなくなっちゃうんですね
で 見つけても その 例えば被害者の人々をね
殺してはいけないんです
もうただのね もう出家して誰かの行者を殺したことだから
これはとんでもないことになります
それだけで自分の社会的な立場なくなりますね
だからそうやって逃げたりも
逃げることでもしていましたしね
それを見て お釈迦様はね
罪から逃げられませんよという話はね
と言ってるの それだけなんです
逃げようと思ったって逃げられませんと
で おそらくどう見たっても
例えばすごい豊かで裕福な家庭でいて
それで何か罪を犯しちゃうと
で バレる前にこそこそと出家してしまうと
そうすると豊かな人っていうのはかなり派手に生活している人だから
これ裸になって髪の毛も剃ってしまって
あの体中いろいろ灰やらいろんな汚れやらいっぱい付けちゃっていると
わからない 誰かと それでずっと生活する
お釈迦様から見れば お前罪を受けてるんではないか
[笑い]このアホっていう感じなんですね
結局 やった犯した罪の罰をとっくに受けてるんですよ
どこへ逃げるんですかとね
家に戻ったら まあ刑法でやる
家出たらそこで自分で
だから悪いことをするなよと
すごいわかりやすい話なんよ
お釈迦様の話は まあ一応まあお釈迦様にこの
パーリ語のテキストにありますからね
この地を経典でもよくムンダカという国と言っている
それがあの彼女が南無と称したところで
バラモン人たちが随分態度崩れちゃって
ものすごい叱ったり怒鳴ったりしたんですね
だから この差別感というかね
自分だけ唯一で正しいとかね
そういう恐ろしい考え方っていうのは
当時のバラモン人にもありました
それをお釈迦様はものすごい丁寧に全部壊したんです
壊したんだけど バラモン教
ヒンドゥー教を壊したわけじゃないんです
それがずっと健在ですけど
でも立派な宗教には成り代わったんです
それもお釈迦様のすごい智慧のところなんです
まあ一緒に仲良くやりましょうと
でも あなた方のとんでもない恐ろしい性格は直すぞと言って
カースト制度もかなり激しく壊しましたし
だから裏でカーストをみんな結婚やらいろんなもう家に入る時やら食べる時やら
もういまだに厳密にやってますけど
公でではもうそれほどできません
仕事を面接に行った時は
君は何カーストですか？とか
それは聞いてはいけません
インドの憲法も不可触民族の人が作った憲法なんですよ
アンベッドカールさん教授ですけどね
アンベッドカール教授が作った憲法なんです
インドの憲法って   年も頑張ってますけど
その憲法で で 時々この汚い人々がね
大学なんかにこのそういうカーストの人々が学生で入って入っちゃうとね
暴動を起こしたり 追い出せと言ったりするという時々起きますけど
汚い醜い現象がね それでもまあ頑張る人は頑張って
ちゃんと社会の一応自分の立場を作ります
ですから この商売して豊かになったりとかね
それはよくありますよ
ですから お釈迦様はカーストは難題と
頑張ればいいんじゃないかと
いくら踏ん張っちゃっても
カースト差別感の人々はね
何もできないんだと 結局は
だからそういうことで
それもインドの当時の社会ででもあったことで
時々カーストは低いんだけど
ものすごい真面目に頑張る
頑張るとどんどん豊かになってくる
バラモン人がもう怠けているんだから
もうお金も何もなくて
乞食やらなくちゃいけない
その場合はカーストは低いのに
その人々からいろいろ教えやらね
お布施やら受けなくちゃいけないことになる
お互い様は裁量だからね
だからザマ見ろということなんですよ
もう出家だったら別にどうったことはないんだけどね
だからお釈迦さんはそういう現象を見て
だから頑張りなさいよと
だからお釈迦様はカースト制度にしたっての
決して上のカーストに対して怒るなよと
憎しむなよという立場なんですよ
だから差別されて搾取されていても
搾取する側 差別する側に対して何の憎しみ
プットカスカにも怒りなく
平和で問題解決 だから後からもいいんですよ
例えばバラモン人やらカーストの上人々を壊して暴動を起こして
家を焼いて大変なことをして
なんとかその一時的に勝ったのようになっても
それから生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
またそれからそういう人々と一緒に
だから結局永遠に争いが終わらなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 相手を貶すことはしない
侮辱することもしない
害も与えない 与えないで
自分が自分の能力で頑張って
もういい位置になって
優しさで見せてあげる
アンベッドカールさんみたいに
だから見せてあげる どうですかと
人間というのは インド独立する時でも
もう彼がかなりの役割を果たしたし
彼ものすごい頭が良くて
弁護士でまた教授までありましたし
だからみんな彼にお願いします
お願いしますと 彼も私のカーストこそっていうことが何のことなく
インド国民みんなのために
もうイギリス政府といろいろ話し合ったりして
それから自分で知識人のあのローヤーたちのグループを作って憲法を制定して
これでどうですかと 例えばスリランカの政府の憲法作っても
最初はやっぱりイギリス人が来て
いろいろ作ったんだから
自分たちで手で作ったってことはない
その憲法は捨てましたけど
後で で インドはそうではなかったんです
イギリス人の意見は全然聞いてないんです
自分たちで作るんだと
作ったものはアンベッドカール教授が作ったんだから
それを読んでみたら もうイギリス政府にも何も言えないんですよ
すごい完璧ではないかと
日本の憲法作ってもアメリカ人が作ったものでしょうしね
ですから やっぱりすごい人っていうのは
そういうことで 全部行為の
自分の生き方の結果なんですね
だからこのバラモン人たちも激しくこの他宗教に対してこの攻撃するということもありましたし
それでこのバラモンたち
バラモン 特にこの旦那がかなりもうこれに怒って
じゃあお釈迦様をものすごい徹底的に侮辱してやるんだと
言って お釈迦様の前でできるだけ失礼に行動したんです
で インド文化の場合は
やっぱり年上の人には礼をする
お釈迦様にはちゃんと礼をしなくちゃいけない
まるっきり礼をしない
なんかもう家の召使いにやったような感じで
この人結構年下ですよ
それでこの仕切りはすごい厳しい
目上の人が座ってるんだったら
自分も座ってしゃべるんです
目上の人が立ってるんだったら
自分も立ってしゃべるんです
目上の人が歩きながらしゃべりたければ
自分も一緒に後ろから歩くんです
で 目上の人がそちらへ座りなさいと言ったならば
それは別で そちらへ座って話を聞きなさいって
目上の方が歩きながらしゃべったっても
それはそれで構いませんし
お釈迦さんはこの社会で一般的に認めているこの決まりには厳しいんです
むちゃくちゃ厳しいわけじゃなくて
本当に社会の秩序 いわゆる目上の人っていうのは先輩たちでしょうに
その方々を尊敬しない社会は崩れちゃいますよと
子供から若者やらみんな目上の先輩の方々にいつでも頭を下げて礼をして挨拶をして
一歩引いて生活しなくちゃいけないと
そうすると目上の人々はものすごい大事にお前たちを守ってあげるんだと
知らないものは全部教えてあげるんだと
ちょっとちょっと失敗したっても
それは何とかして まあ何とかして何とかしてあげるんだよと
それであんた方はきちんとした一人前に育て上げるんだよと
だから席割り礼ぐらいでもね
やってもらわないと 日本の社会の問題もそういう問題なんですよ
この席割りっていうのはね
目上の人を尊敬するとかね
それはもうむちゃくちゃ壊れてるんですね
今あるのは単なる格好だけ
学校の先生は何の立場もない
ただ軍隊の礼みたいにみんな起立と言って礼と言ってそれに座るだけで
もう先生馬鹿にしているんですよ
それであの心から通じる愛情と責任感というのは生まれてこない
ただの義務で 義理でやってるだけ
だから子供たちは本当に
我々は目上の人々に尊敬するように育てたならば
尊敬は大したことないんですよ
ただ心の気持ちだけなんですけど
だからそうするとやっぱり年上の人々というのは
なんとなく自然に若子ではないかという責任感を感じるんですよ
学校の先生でも その場合はすごく責任感感じる
放っておけないと なんとかしてあげようと
そうすると先生うるさいとも思えないんですね
言うことを聞きたくもなるし
だからその関係っていうのはずっと続くんですね
だから我々年取ったってもいい先生でしたねとかね
亡くなったと聞いたら
さっさと走ってその葬式に行きたくなるし
命日に行って線香 1本でもあげたくなるし
だからその人間関係っていうのは死ぬまで続くんですよ
それで生きることは楽しくて楽になるんです
人を見て あー嫌だ嫌だと思わないんです
だから 仏教の世界では精神的な病気の人というのは成り立たないんです
どこでも 逆に仏教は現代いろいろ病気に対して何何を教えているかと聞いたっても
これは大きな迷惑なんです
仏教は西洋よりもものすごい優れている心理学を教えていますけど
それは精神分裂病やらね
多重人格症を動かしている人やらね
そういう人々のために教えているものじゃなくて
インテリ中のインテリに教えている心理学なんです
だから普通の人にはそれは理解も何もできない世界なんです
仏教の心理学はね だから聞いたっても
本当は答えにくいんですよ
ストレス解消にどうしようかとかね
もう会社の人間関係はガタガタで
なんとかならないんでしょうか
方法とかね ない そんなバカどもにできるものは
なぜならば 基本的な人間として生きていれば
そんな問題は出てこないんですよ
だから 人間としての最低基準も守ってないんですよ
だからそこをもう仏教入るところじゃないんです
人間としてもう完璧に生きていて
何一つ問題ないというところに仏教が入ってくるんです
これだけでダメですよと
より成長しなさいというところが仏教の仕事の始まりもいわゆる土台なんですね
だからそういうところでかなり難しいところですよ
仏教は現代人に喋る場合は
現代人は聞くところというのは
もうあまりにも小さくてレベル低いところで
我々にとっては あれ そんな問題あるんでしょうか？というね
例えば姑さんと嫁さんの喧嘩
なんで？って なんで喧嘩する？仲良くすればいいでしょう
それだけ なんで？それは現代人とは大変乗り越えられない問題なんですね
だから仏教の世界ではもう考えたこともない
考えたこともないことなんですよ
自分が自分の親戚とかね
親戚って言うし まあお互いにもう仲良くすると言ったっても
いろいろ言い合ったりはしますよ
それまた楽しくてね 特にお嫁さんというのはお嫁さんとは言わないんですよ
みんなこのもう自分の息子かどこかからね
女の子連れてくると それがすごい喜ぶんですね
だからものすごい喜んで
もう家に頂くというかね
だから 1日2日でも何のことなくみんなのとこ溶けちゃってね
もう家の一員になってしまうんです
ですから この まあバリバリのおばさんだったらね
なんとなく仕事が減っていくとね
やっぱりちょっと寂しいというところはありますけど
その場合はお寺があるんだからね
その場合はお寺に行ったらもういくらでも仕事があります
それで苦労しながらお寺のいろんな仕事をしますからね
やはり信者さんの管理やら集めることやら
いろんなことをもう料理の面倒を見ることやらもう大変ですよ
若者またまとめてもらうことやらね
またかえってよりすごい活発的に社会に入ることはできるし
ですから 一旦自分の息子を結婚して一人歩きできるようになったということは
女性にとっては第2の人生
もっとより広く強く第2の人生するというのができるんですね
それから初めて もう村中やら町中やら知られと知られている人物になるんですよ
子供だけ面倒見ていると
もうあまりそんなに知られているわけじゃないんですね
だからそういう世界から見ると
何？っていうところになるんですよ
まあ兄弟喧嘩はまあ小さい時とかもあったりするんだけど
まあたまたま大きいになったってもある場合あるんだけど
その時でもやっぱりこれは決していけませんというところはもう確実にあって喧嘩するんですね
ですからまあ で それはおかしいこと
だから兄弟お互いにものすごい憎しみあって喧嘩したっても
それで ある兄弟と友達がいて
別な人が その友達がその兄弟の悪口言ったら怒るんですよ
自分がものすごく憎しんでるんだけど
弟のことはね 友達もやっぱりあいつはとんでもない人
お前何を言ってるんしょうかと
すごい弟の肩抱くの その場合
だからおかしいんです
とにかく よく昔 国会 スリランカのパーリメントによくあったことで
弟が野党で もう兄貴が与党とか
そういうふうには別な党でね
政治的にはすっごい激しくやったりしますよ
そうすると 兄貴の党の人が自分の発言するときは
向こうはもう反対側だからね
何か言ったらものすごい嫌味を言われるところだからね
この人怒るんですよ 同じ党なのに
それでみんな笑っちゃうのは
やっぱりこの血は水より硬い
濃いということさがあるんだからね
やっぱりそれは理解しますよ
それはまあそれはもうしょうがない
これはもう決して切れない関係だからね
まあそういうふうにすごいこのお互いに仲良くするということが基本で
当たり前で それにはもうこれはもう絶対
何て言いますか 権利というかね
侵せない条件ですね そういうことが侵せない条件として置いておかないと
だから絶対人間には侵すってことはいけない
この基本中基本の条件
堂々破ってるんだから
金のみ大事であって という文化でしょ
現代文化っていうのは
だから親子関係でも夫婦関係はどうでもいいんだよ
そんなものは 先生と生徒の関係でもね
それより金 それより金ということ
だから我々はあの あの
人間として絶対侵すことできない
変更できない 変化できない
侵すことできない基本条件というかね
それを破っているんだから
不幸になったり 精神的に病気になったり
イカれたりするのは普通です
だってそれは人間が平和で豊かで生きるために必要なものなんですね
人間が呼吸する空気 汚したこと
汚したことと同じなんですよ
我々は自然な空気を吸っていると元気でしょうし
その空気を汚し汚しちゃうと
それは絶対やってはいけないことでしょう
大気汚染というのは それだったら病気になるんだということは当たり前のことで
だから我々は基本的に必要なものはもうおかしくちゃって
もう大変な苦しみになっているんですね
まあそれはまあそういう
ですから この今現代あるこの精神的な病気というのは
全てこの西洋輸入なんですね
このストレスとかね 分裂とか
全部西洋輸入ですよ それだからといって
この仏教の世界やらね
アジアの世界でも精神的な病気はない
それはないわ あります
それは別突然親が死んでしまったとかね
それそのショックにはもうちょっと対応できないと
もうかなりお互いに愛情があるでしょうに
だから親がない生活って何なのかとわからなくなっちゃうんです
たとえ親が年取っていても
やっぱりお互いに心配し合ったり甘えたりするんだからね
親が消えちゃったら なんかちょっとこれ受け取れなくなるとかね
子供が死んじゃったとかね
そういう出来事で もう頭ちょっとおかしくなってしまうっていうことで
そういうのはあります
あるいはこの まあまあ
昔王様たちでしたからね
それで王様に捕まえられちゃって
自分の旦那とかね 殺されたとかね
しちゃうと もう腹が立っても訴えられないんですね
どうにもならんだから
相手は王様だから それでやっぱりその苦しみがね
自分にあの帰ってきて
頭がすごいひどい状態になるということはありますけど
その場合はもう直してあげることはできます
そういうケースはすぐ簡単に直せます
こちらも聞いているある方がね
名前言っちゃいけないんですから言わないんですけどね
旦那が亡くなったってことすっごいもう家も出ないでずっと泣いてばっかしてたんだそうっていうことで
それでも性格ももうむちゃむちゃ
旦那がいる時はすごい豪華に召使い召使いではなくてね
お手伝いさんまで連れていて贅沢していたみたいし
旦那が亡くなったらどんどんどんどんね
子供が別々になっちゃうとね
そういう生活もできなくなっちゃう
でもあの状況から頭離れませんね
ですから もうものすごい精神状態で
でも私の勉強会に一回来て
それでももう六十パーセント経過したし
それからちょっとする喋っただけで
あれなくて 全部もう綺麗さっぱり捨てちゃったんだからね
かなり元気になりました
それからも体の病気でずっと私をいじめていたんですけどね
それはもうどうにもならないし
治せ治らないし 長い間のね
結果だからね それでも私と喋ると
私に怒られてもすぐもう治るんだと
で また出てくるんですね
まあですから その場合はもう心がおかしくなったっていうことは別に不思議なことでもなくて
やっぱり心が受け取れないんですね
この人が亡くなったっていうことは
それで人生まとめに生きていられなくなっちゃいますね
それはもう治せますよ
でもこの基本的な 例えばもうどうとも親御さんがね
互いにやりあっていて
それで精神的に病気になってくると
もう治しようがないんですね
よくどう頑張っても なぜかというと
これはもう人間の基本的な条件破ってるんだからね
仏の明かしなさいっていうことは基本的な条件で
それをもうまあ治せますけど
仏教で治せない病気ってのはないんだから
治せることは治せますけどね
でもただそれだけに時間を無駄に使いたくないんですね
自分一人でできるところは一人でやってほしいしね
まあこのしきたりについて
仏教 まあこのストーリーになってくると
大体いくらかインド文化やらね
そのうるさいした方がよろしいんだから言ったんですけど
インド文化っていうのは一応そのしきたりは大事にする
厳しく大事にする でお釈迦様は大事にしていました
でもお釈迦様は無意味な社会に迷惑なしきたりはもうきれいさっぱり捨てたんです
でも社会秩序を守る しきたりっていうのはきちんと守る
時々あるバラモンたちには激しく言うんですよ
ある若いバラモンがね
みんなで年上の長老たちと一緒に来て
バラモン人のみんな有名な人々で
でも長老たちがその十八歳ぐらいの若者なんですよ
わざと連れてきたんですよ
なぜかというと この天才的な能力があったんですね
全部学問も全部もう完成していて
一人前にしてやったんですよ
まだ二十歳にもなってないのに
それで まあバラモン人の社会で
この八十歳の七十歳の
といえばもう神様扱いですよ
そういう人々の間で また有名な人の間で
もう一人ま一人前の扱いで
連れてきたんです お釈迦様の会う時でも
その若者も じゃあどうせどうせもう喋るのは私でしょうと
みんな代表してという気持ちで
行ったんですよ 行ったらもうお釈迦様はわざと彼と喋らないんですね
もうこの有名な他のバラモンたちと色々ある人々はどうですかとかね
それなんとか会話から次の人でどうでしょうかね
そうですかねとか なんかいろいろ普通の日常会話化してるんですね
だから年上だからね 本当にわざわざせっかくね
来て大変でしょうとかなんとかとかね
元気でしょうかとか ごく普通の会話をしている
だからこの若者はなんとなく自分を苛々させているんですね
でもお釈迦様は順番で行くぞとわざと決めたんです
それはお釈迦様が考えている社会の決まりなんですよ
八十歳のすごい有名な方がいる
目の前にいる時は 子供で
じゃあ君元気？とか冗談じゃないんですよ
まず目上の人と挨拶して
それからその人から紹介してもらって
これうちの孫ですけど
あ そうですか 君の名前は？それから聞くんですよ
だから僕も日本でもよくやることでね
目上の人が目下の人を紹介してあげなくちゃいけない
そうすると まあそれでまあかなりの人だったら
それはそれ それからはいくら何でも褒めてあげることはできます
それでこの若者は口を出すんです
お釈迦様は黙っていなさい
いきなり お前行儀を知らないかと
私は今ウッダーナン・マハッラカーナン
ものすごい長老たちと
バラモン人の 話してる最中ではないかと
下がれと ものすごいいっぱい出てきちゃったんです
引っ込めてるんですよ
あの場合は 引き下がる
引き下がる 私はものすごいこの有名なこの長老たちと喋ってるんだから
基本的な行儀 しきたり
言ったらもうどうにもならなくて
ものすごく小さくなって
もうもうすごくもう引いちゃって引いたんですよ
それをショック与えてから
あのことを若者とはよく喋りましたけどね
でもかすかにでも いくら頭良くたっても
社会秩序を守るしきたりは
もうこれは基本的な条件で変えられませんと
頭がいいということで
それであんたには人間の基本的な権利
ごちゃごちゃすることはできないという立場を取ってるんですね
その場合は それから長老たちがね
あの お釈迦様 まああの子をね
まあそんなにもう厳しく批判しないでくださいと
この子は本当は大変な大物ですよと言って紹介してくれるんですよ
それで紹介したら 本人もやっぱりちょっと落ち着いたし
でお釈迦様それ以上何も言わなかったし
まあそれでこの若者が
じゃあそれだったら もう私のことも知ってるんだから
お釈迦様 じっと黙ってるんだと
やがてお釈迦様が話を終わって私の顔を見るでしょうと
その時喋りますと言って
おとなしく やっぱり頭がいいんですよ
おとなしく待っていたんですね
それでお釈迦様は長老たちと話を終わって
最後にあの若者の顔を見たんですね
顔を見たら まあそれで彼が話し始めたんです
それで経典が彼との会話で進んでいくんですよ
やっぱり長老たちが何のことなく
もう黙って聞いていただけ
本当にディスカッションで若者とお互いに話し合ったり
質問したり答えたり ずっと続けていたんですよ
なのに最初はそうじゃないんです
態度は しきたりはもう犯すことはできない
だからまあそこら辺でも
まあ本当に我々には役に立つすごい教えがね
あるんですよ だから経典そのものではなくて
この経典の裏にある だからまあそこら辺でも
まあ本当に我々には役に立つすごい教えがね
あるんですよ だから経典そのものではなくて
この経典の裏にあるところは
まあ当たり前だからお釈迦様あまり教えてないんですよ
でも そういうところも大変大事なんですよ
我々の人格形成する場合は
そこら辺勉強したいならば
学者の方々だったら戒律のテキストの中にあります
でも残念なことに この戒律のその裏は読めないんですね
みんなに ただ項目だけ計算する
この裏にある戒律の項目ではなくて
この人間としての このどうしても犯すことのできない基本的なこの人間関係
この社会というシステムの中で生きてなさいと
人間というのは集団動物やと
そこでハチ ミツバチは一人で生活できませんからね
この群れでいなくちゃいけないんですよ
群れでいるんだったら
群れの決まりを守るのはもう当たり前で
当然で もう犯せないんですね
決まりがぶったら自分の命はないということになります
私の隣に 私が寝るところに生活している
あのミツバチがね ものすごい今年大きくなってますけどね
やっぱりドア閉めてますけど
まあたまたまなんとかわけあってドア開けてあると光が入っちゃいますから
すっと光を通しても反応的に来るんですよ
1匹に匹来てもものすごく悲しくなっちゃいますよ
あ かわいそうや だから出たらまあそれで終わり
死んじゃいます まあ夜一緒に寝るでしょうに
だから太陽の光が出てくると
また仕事に行くでしょ
そこで我々は人工的なね
電気を夜ずっと使ってるんだから
それ目に触れちゃうと
目に触れるかどうかわかりませんだけど
大体まあ背中の方に感じるみたいですけどね
感じちゃうと自然に飛んでくるんですね
飛んできて このあの電球にこの背中をつけて
ずーっとぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる動いてるんですね
だから太陽は背中で感じるでしょうと私も思いますね
だからまあ それでもうもう戻れない
もう死んじゃいますね
それにもう悲しいんですね
だからできるだけ気をつけ
もうかなり迷惑なんですけど
もう使えないんですよ
2階は 昼はもう使えるんだけど
夜何か用事があって 何か荷物でも取ろうかなとかね
もう行くともう何匹かまあ
命が終わり  [背景音楽]ですが
この戒律の中の五つ本ありますからね
その中でもあるのは項目というよりも
やっぱりこの出家の でもいたっても集団だからね
それをどういうふうに生きるべきかということね
それがすごいすごいことなんですよ
だから 一つ一つの戒律項目は二種類ありますけど
個人の人格形成のために個人の煩悩
汚す煩悩がなくすための戒律と
サンガとしての生き方という 2つに綺麗に分けてます
だから どんな項目を見てもすぐ我々は分かりますよ
これは個人に対する戒めか
サンガとしての社会に対する一人としての戒めかということ
それははっきりしている
その中でも厳しいのは社会に対する戒めなんですよ
個人が個人で失敗しても
また謝って 自分でまたやり直せばいいでしょうに
じゃあやり直しは難しい
やり直しは難しくはないんですけど
一応厳しいんです 座る順番とか
それはすごい厳しい たとえ間違ってでも
出家としての年下の人の礼節はいけないんです
それは社会の一員としての
例えば同じ日で比丘戒を受けたならば
何時ですか？と聞くんですよ
それで三時に出家儀式終了した人が年上で
三時二十分で昇卿儀式終了した人は年下なんです
それぐらいきめ細かい
個人に当てはまる戒律の場合はもう謝れと
またやり直せということで終わっちゃうんです
まあそのバラモンがお釈迦様礼儀もしないでね
もう 立ったまんまで座ろうともしない
なんかすごい気持ち悪いという感じで立ったまんまでお釈迦様と話して
かなりお釈迦様に失礼なことをしたと思いますけどね
結局質問したんですよ
キンス・ジャヒットはスカン・セーティ
何を捨てれば安らかにいられますかと
キンス・ジャヒットはネソーチェティ
何を捨てれば悩めないでしょうか
キッサッサエカダンマッサワダンローチェーシゴータマ
もし全面的に否定してなくせというならば
一つのものが これはお釈迦様は何と思いますかと
いわゆるお釈迦様が一つ
人が絶対これだけはもう絶対もうなくせと
全面的に消せと 消せと言うならば
これが何なのかと これは質問ミスなんですね
お釈迦様は一つの答えで答えるんです
コーダン・ジャットワ・スカンセーティ
怒りを捨てたら安楽に落ち着いていられますよと
それで怒りを捨てたら悩まないんだよと
私はこのコーダッサ・ヴィサモーラッサ・マドゥラッガッサ
怒りというのは このものすごい毒が猛毒が入ってますよ
でもマドゥラッガッサ
でも糖衣と言うんでしょうか
砂糖 表は甘いんだよ でも中はものすごい猛毒だと
だから怒りっていうのはもうすぐ死んでしまう猛毒なんですけど
かなり甘い糖衣で巻いてるんですね
それが絶対ダメやと言ってるんだよと
言って結局言い返しちゃったんですよ
そのバラモンがかなり怒っていたんだから
だからお釈迦様の真理は自由自在だからね
怒りだけ絶対的 それだけなくせという風にこの偈で教えてるんだけど
ただその偈だけ人が勉強して
お釈迦様はそれしか教えない
それは絶対だと言ったらそんなことない
他の偈見ればまたありますからね
違うものを ワダン・アリア・パサン・サンティ・タン・ヒ・ジャットワ・ナ・ソーチェティという
これ別な経典でお釈迦様
サンユッタ・ニカーヤだと思います
で 出てくる偈なんですね
やっぱりそれを聞いたら
あのバラモン人がお釈迦様に対してすごく怒っていたんですね
怒っていた時 同時にものすごくもう苛立ちもあったんですよ
奥さんとはうまくいかないわ
話はもう合わないわ 自分が大変苦しいわね
バラモン人との付き合いの付き合いで
関わりで それからバラモン人にむちゃくちゃ叱られて貶されちゃって
自分がすっごいもう嫌な状況
だから奥さんのせいであろうとも
バラモン人が自分を叱ったでしょうに
貶しちゃったでしょうに
だからその場合はバラモン人の立場を取るわけにはいきませんよ
自分の奥さんだからね
だから奥さんはもうあいつはもうバカもんなんで
もうもうそんないつでもそんなもんだからという風に守ってあげたいんですね
まあどうせ守らなくちゃいけないんだからね
自分の奥さんをね たとえいろいろおかしいところあっても
変なところあっても やっぱり旦那はもうそれはもうちゃんと庇ってあげて
もう何とかしてあげるんですね
だから人の前でちょっと何かしたってても
すぐ男はそれはもう何とかしてあげる
ですから やっぱりその場で必ずも自分の奥さんの立場を取るのは当たり前のことで
でも奥さんのせいで もう散々自分がその怒り
罰を受けなくちゃいけないんですね
罰を受けちゃうとこちらも腹が立ってくるんですよ
そこまで言う必要あるかと
自分の奥さんのことについて
もうただの女の人は自分勝手で何やっててもいいんじゃないかと
私の奥さんではないかという気持ちも出てくるのでしょうね
あんた方に何だいと だからかなりこのもう混乱状態にいたんですね
で バラモンたちが帰ったところで
まあ奥さんに当たるんですね
お前のせいでという それでもうバラモンたちが帰るまで待っていて
そこで奥さんに当たって夫婦喧嘩になったんですけど
それでもう奥さんももうめげないんだから
もう仏教の信者さんとして
じゃああんたの先生に言って
もうそんなに偉いかと聞いてみるぞということで行ったんだけど
やっぱり自分に対してものすごい悩み
憎しみ 苦しみってあったんですね
その上でお釈迦様にすごい失礼なことをしたって
お釈迦様は別にそれ全然気にしなかったこと
だいたいお釈迦様は返事しませんよ
立って質問すると なのにそれもなくすごい優しく答えたし
挨拶もしましたし それでどうすれば落ち着けるでしょうかねと
聞いたら怒りなくせと
すぐ分かったんで 自分がこの社会でゴチャゴチャいくらあったっても
それはもうたくさんありますけど
それに怒るなよと 奥さんの性格は悪いかもしれませんし
自分の宗教は信仰してくれないかもしれませんし
バラモン人がいろいろ
それは社会の出来事だからね
いろんなゴチャゴチャの出来事が起こるんですけど
でもまあそれに いやいけません
いけませんとかね それに怒るなよと
だからそこで生きる智慧がすぐその人の心に入ったんですね
たとえ何か法事とかなんとかとかね
設定してもうまくいかないとかね
いろいろ道具揃わないとか
人に頼んだのに持ってきてないとか
いろんな出来事起こるんですよ
だからそういうのはごく普通で
もう例えば突然台風が来て電車がなくなって
もうないとかね 時間に間に合わなかったとかね
もうそうやって日常生活にもいろんな出来事は起こる
それは避けられません
ですから それに怒らないこと
それが智慧であると ということを教えてもらって
バラモン人が結局その日その瞬間で喜びを感じたんですね
どれほど喜びを感じたんですかというと
彼がやっぱりこれが道だと
自分の家内が本当にすごいとよくわかっていたんだと言って
もうやっぱり家内に負けてはたまりませんだからね
先輩だからね で 出家しちゃったんです
出家して修行して阿羅漢になりましたけどね
で 奥さんもそれに反対わけじゃない
自分がものすごい自分より先に悟ってるんだからね
それはすごいありがたいことで
それで彼の弟なんですね
で それで彼の弟がもうかなり怒って
この出家したことをね
お釈迦様にこの計画立てて非難
侮辱するそうと 言って家に呼んだんだ
お釈迦様に お布施しますと
言って まあ一応食事とかは用意してやったんですけど
お釈迦様を家に呼んだのは接待するためじゃないんです
家に来てすっごく侮辱してやるそうで
それはものすごい響くんですよ
まあ来てくださいと言って
それでさんざん侮辱されちゃうと
帰ったっても惨めで惨めで
人の家にご飯食べようと行ったところで
もうご飯ではなくて ものすごくもう侮辱されちゃったと
後味もものすごい最低なんですね
自分に惨めになるんですよ
なんで私がこの食うために
そこまで惨めになるんかと気持ちなるんで
そこまで計算したんです
計算してお釈迦様を家に呼んだんです
お釈迦様は行きました
一応座ってから この人ものすごいお釈迦様に叱ったんです
釈迦様は全部聞いていたんです
そしたら終わったんですけど
それでですね お釈迦様
何のことなく 私はあなたに接待されてきましたけどね
それであなた 私に十分怒り
憎しみという接待をいたしましたと
で 残念なことに私はそれいただけませんと
もう開始しました それをまずたとえで人は捕まったんです
あんたに聞きますけど
あなたの家でもパーティーとか
大げさにね 親戚を呼んで
ものすごい豪華なご馳走して接待するとしますね
あんたの親戚も有名な
ものすごい有名な人々でしたからね
あんたご馳走作ると それでみんな忙しくて
なんとか訳があって来られなくなると
それであなたがあのご馳走はどうしますかと
まあそういう場合は それは私と家族と子供たちと食べますと
まあそう それでですね
あなたは私を招待して
この罵倒という叱りとか憎しみという接待をいたしましたけど
残念ながら私はそういうのはいただけないんですと
だから あなたとあなたの子供たちと親戚
家族とみんなでどうぞ味わってくださいと
何のことなく返しちゃったんですね
それでも負けちゃったんですね
やっぱり こんなに落ち着いてる人を叱って何なのかというと
それで彼も結局出家となってしまう
それから何人か次から次へと
お釈迦様はその出来事でね
ぶつかって 結局出家したりとかね
仏教徒になったりしましたしね
それスンデリカ・バーラッドワージャーというバラモン人とビランギック・バーラッドワージャーという
二人ともバーラッドワージャー家族で有名ですよ
バーラッドワージャーというのはかなり上ですよ
バラモンのカーストの中でもすごい上なんです
あのバーラッドワージャーというのはヴェーダ聖典を作った仙人たちの中の一人の家なんですね
そうやってこのその家族やら
このバーラッドワージャー系のもう大物のバラモンたちにも
もう何人か次から次へと出家してしまったんですよ
だから これバラモン教にしたって
もうちょっとまずい状態なんですけど
でも仏教の立場から見れば
もうどんな大物でも入ったことがかえって仏教に対してはすごく役に立ちます
みんなもう知識人だから
ある面では役に立ちますよ
もうアホじゃないんだからね
いくらアホなことしたっても
だから能力もあるしね
そういう人々は本当に仏教をそれから大事に守って広げたりしましたしね
とにかくこの出来事っていうのは
みんなお釈迦様を侮辱しようとしたんですよ
この有名なグループが
バーラッドワージャー系が
そこでこのバーラッドワージャー系っていうのは
このインドの偉大なるバラモンの家で
四人四人しか残っていなかったんですけど
八人か十いくつかの覚えていらっしゃるでしょうかの方もわからないんですけど
このアンギーワーセット
もう私忘れちゃったんですけどね
その仙人たちの名前が
アンギー・アンギーワーセット・バーラッドワージャーなんとか何とかとかね
名前あります そのもう八人九人ぐらいのある中の一人ですからね
そのグループがね みんな出家しちゃったんだからね
それでまた面白いことに
みんなお釈迦様を侮辱して貶してやるぞと思っちゃったんだから
結局そんなことになったんだということが話題になるんですね
それでお釈迦様がやっぱり力っていうのは
そういう財産でも怒りでも憎しみでもないんだよと
私はすごい軍隊を持ってるんだと
それには勝てないんだ
誰でも 私が持ってるすごい軍隊っていうのは
この忍耐ですよと いくら罵倒されても
いくら貶されても 別に気にしないと
楽しく聞いていて それなりに反応するという
それがバラモンのいわゆる阿羅漢の本当のバラモンがそういう人やと
心が落ち着いていること
怒りに怒りで憎しみに憎しみに返さない人やという
で 時間になりましたので
まあ一つだけで終了します
まあこの一つだけでも
現代世界状況考えると
まあ我々はまあ一人静かに社会から離れて
本当の道はこういう道ではないかということを覚えた方がいいんですね
世の中っていうのは憎しみで
あの 学習することを報復することとかね
それで問題解決するんだと
それで我々は安全になるんだという
ものすごい誤解に陥っていて
結局世界は危険な目に遭うだけ
で 例えばいくら報復したっても
報復すればするほど過激派が強くなる
いわゆる訳が成り立つの
潰すために どうせ出来の悪い人々だからね
どうせ頭が悪い おかしい
おかしいんだから一番危険なんですよ
だから仏教の世界では敵に回すならば
それでも知識人 知恵のある人を敵に回せと
悪いことしないよと 悪人をいくらなんでも敵に回すなよと
何するかわかりませんから
道徳のない 頭の悪い 感情的で
悪人だったらなんとかなんとかおだてて
もう自分の身を守った方がいいんですよ
面と向かって喧嘩するんだったら
やっぱりその相手がすごい道徳があって
知識がある人がね 敵であろうとも知識のある人をね
知恵の人は悪いことしませんと
だって頭がいいんだから
人を悪くすれば自分に返ってくるでしょうに
しません 無視する まあ敵だと知ってるんだけど
だから何とかする なんとかしちゃったらそこで大変だと
自分の立場がなくなるんだと
自分が不幸になるんだと
だから何もしません だから敵に回すんだったら
やっぱりそれでも知恵の悪い人でしょうに
それは我々仏教がいう世界であって
これも生まれつき精神的な病気の人々
それから教育上 さらに精神錯乱させる教育で
訓練もさらに精神混乱するような訓練を受けている
それからもう隔離制で
それから知識は絶対もう鍵かけてあって広げない
他の教えは他人の教え思考
何も理解しようともしないという
ものすごい妄想の殻の中に生きている人々を敵に回すということは
もう それはとんでもないことなんです
[背景音楽]では マハーハンシーラ・スッバーナ・ハンシーラ・スッバーナ・スッ